now we begin with breaking news coming
out of the Democratic Republic of Congo
UN peacekeepers have shot dead two
protesters after more than a thousand
people stormed a UN base in the town of
Beni the protesters are angry about an
increasing number of attacks by rebels
in the area the city appears to be on
lockdown and gunshots can be heard
earlier at least eight people were
killed in an overnight assault blamed on
a rebel group calling itself the allied
democratic forces well Elaine you a
Connie
al Jazeera producer is on the line from
Benny where the shootings happened just
tell us what you were seeing and hearing
at the moment what I've experienced
myself this morning the situation still
very terse but in the morning it was
more testable you can see in the
previous image come such people
attacking the men you and will team in
the town of Bennett and the UN soldier
they were trying to defend themselves
defender pulled him but it was very
difficult than two people were just
killed in the demonstration just around
the UN can they have like destroying the
half part of the wall of this main
building and now what is happening
around this the same protesters are now
eating to the second military base of
the UN located at the airport this is
completely it's very very difficult
situation which is going on in the town
of being here the protest still going on
up to the night time now we are going
already
we don't know what will happen in the
coming hours a line just explained this
to us because there has been a lot of
tension in recent days between the UN
and also protesters there and they
signed they don't feel that they're
being protected is that right this is
the main cause of the protest because
6th November they have been experienced
people of the town of Beni and in
surrounding they have been experienced
the killing the regularly killing from
the 80s 10 people 20 people 15 people
have been killed every week by the ADF
rebels then these people saying they
don't feel safe the UN has a mandate to
protect the population but now they feel
like this mandate is not for this
anything back this is why they want you
when to leave this place the main cause
to attack me or the business is to send
a message telling them that you are
failed to protect the most suitable day
the population and when I also the
government soldiers they are failed they
are killing both of them that they have
failed to protect civilian this map
again they have killed 8 people and they
are not safe even tomorrow they said
that we may be killed again
so you and must lead so that the
government of the year he may take his
responsibility because for them the UN
presence is disturbing the government
from taking is the responsibility this
responsibility which is the main rule is
to protect the civilian in the Bailey
kit is the main cause of what is
happening here align just explain this
force for people who are just coming to
this story and saying what's playing out
here for the the Congolese forces have
stepped up their attacks on the idea of
the Allied democratic forces explain
that conflict for us this idea they have
been in the forest of painting nearest
APD town here for more than taking the
DRC Armed Forces we have lost city
operation even right now as I'm talking
to you there is a new operation which
was just luck last last week just two
weeks ago but it's not producing
anything the same idea the Army is
fighting in the bush
they say the President himself is for
the last operation to end finally with
these rebels after more than 20 years in
the forest of been here but just very
after the launching of the operation the
same rebels came and they killed in the
town they have been coming for all of
almost the week and they have been
killing people so there is no any impact
of this this this operation this is why
people protesters population of been
they really believe that the government
cannot do anything and UN has failed
also to take over on this idiot rebels
from Uganda well Ryan as you say a very
fluid situation there people have been
killed we're gonna continue tomorrow to
this story thank you again for bringing
us up today